hey welcome back to Marvel live we are
here with two of these stars of Marvel
Studios immense infinity war palm
convinced yet and Paul Bettany Mantis
envision how are you
very very good yes you just came back
from awesome fan signing I looked like a
ton of fun how is that it's great it's
always nice to go out and meet them they
are the best most energetic crazy yeah
it was really sweet to meet the other
kids
were they concerned about your
well-being given the film there has been
a lot of concern and everybody is you
know where where everybody's together
there's a pop up here where you can get
some grief counseling oh I was that did
they hug it out with you we hugged so
Marvel Avengers infinity war we were at
the mirror all day how has it been since
the movies come out like the the
reaction I mean people love this film
it's such an amazing achievement it's
such an amazing movie what's been the
reaction like and now in the aftermath
yeah and people get the experience and
live with it right a lot of people cried
and I've been complaining and saying are
you gonna come back and you know we
can't say anything so where's that yeah
there's only so much hope we can we can
give them but it has been you know again
they're they're great fans are really
respectful and everybody really seem to
love the movie despite having
a real mournful oh yeah there's such an
emotional weight throughout that movie
with the Avengers fighting Panos I
wanted I wanted to ask you because you
are both of you are usually under a lot
of prosthetics and stuff like that but
you in Marchant infinity war you got to
actually just kind of for a second we
see you with Wanda and you guys just
need such a religious University where
you where they're like we got to put
them back on now or you're like please
just one more scene you know what I did
I did get one more scene in initially
the first scene I was gonna be as vision
I said why can't we have a reflection of
him in the window as vision and but him
be and thereby tell the story and so I
got an extra day that's been so fun from
the film is finally getting to see all
these different characters connect and
come together what was it like getting
to how the Guardians have Thor come in
and be part of the team - Jeff what to
have Thor come in and meet up with the
guardians oh it's very funny it was very
funny to see ya to see Thor and
star-lord kind of like II know trying to
be the the smartest and the strongest
then you know it was gonna funny to
watch that you know male ego yeah that's
a great scene in the alpha male
do you also keep in cuz they're like
eight and Avengers text thread but
you're all you're all on send each other
mean yeah but you're the only one that's
not are you all talk about the other
yeah they're a good slug the videos I
don't know we're the best we're the best
people best if it's all about the
guidance all about the event where the
weirdos you know we like that there are
various group threads you know yes
going back to one thing that I person
does about the film is that we get to
see you and one in Europe like kind of
hanging out I got and I was obsessed
with wondering what they were doing just
like hanging out ingress
here in Edinburgh yeah there's lots to
eat did you say that you wanted maybe to
do a movie with just the two the two of
you guys don't recognize what can I get
more tahini sauce on this about where
the shoes were left great yes so is
there one memory from the making this
movie that sticks out to you like it was
there a day that you were like oh man
this is this is this is this is real
that we're we are make we are doing the
infinity one I mean the first day of
shoot you know when we got to do the
scene with tracks
I mean act Dave Bautista Chris Pratt and
Robert Downey jr. and who else Tom
Holland you know it was like all these
franchises together at the same time it
was our first day of shoot and we really
you know we're like oh my god this is
happening now and it's insane you know
because myself I've been a fan of these
movies and I've been a fan of you know
you guys in the first Avengers movies
and you know an Iron Man and and you
know and before getting cast as mantis
you know so when I go watching a movie
when I went Washington movie I was
watching like a fan not a movie that I
wanted you know you know oh and the film
is coming for home release very soon I
am full - yes yes can you tease anything
about what we're gonna see from deleted
scenes or bloopers or or any of that
have you seen them I mean there's some
really funny bloopers that I'm slightly
ashamed there's one in particular where
I literally can't I'm so unprofessional
that I can't stop laughing at Chris
Evans
and that was embarrassing yeah there's a
lot of behind the scenes footage and a
lot of deleted scenes and I think
there's a deleted scene I'm told
somebody told me today there's a deleted
scene between me and and I wonder but I
have no idea what it do you feel me they
got the real actor oh no no this is I'm
very excited for this home relief
because I live our fans they love to
pour over the movie and find little
details and Easter eggs and stuff like
that so are you excited are you gonna
watch movie again and see like why even
do they put that in there I even know
that they even snuck that into the movie
that I was in yeah watch the movie again
oh yeah would you watch it again and
like look for a little more Easter eggs
and stuff like that yeah no I would
watch the other the gags for sure yeah
watch that I really want to see the gag
reel but I have three children and
they'll make me watch when they see the
movies are they doing that thing of like
but Dad it's not that's or do are they
like oh that's vision well I have a 21
year old so he's not I have a 7 year old
she and she's grown up on these sets so
frankly there was one time where I was
worried how she was gonna react to me
being purple and I came out and I was
purple and she ran up and said hello
daddy and she kissed me and then when I
took it off at the end of the day she
would have probably at home that you
like it's kind of been the story of our
relationship since that day it was there
a character in the movie you did not get
to interact with you're like I wish I
had a scene with ya but it hasn't been
on earth yet she's just like stuck in
his space for now so I would have loved
to have scenes with
with you for sure I really really love
of course the action in these movies and
like all that stuff like does it feel
good now that you get to like not have
to do all that physical stuff and like
you can actually like hopefully like not
be sore or stuck in a chair with things
on your face is it nice to have that
reprieve it's definitely nice having
gaps it's really nice to come back it's
it's it's a great group of people in
working with really fantastic actors
fantastic directors and frankly and I'm
you know the best crews in the world you
know the cinematographers the camera
operator on this last CGI to see if your
work we're just the best so it's and
it's really it's a privilege to come
back on to start work again it always
feels good coming back starvation